good afternoon everybody you should
probably get started here welcome every
our symposium on spatial biodiversity
science and conservation at a global
scale
it's the inaugural symposium for a new
program here at Yale that's supported
through hips and the program as well as
the conference symposium is supported
for hips and very grateful for that
support the Yale institute of biospheric
studies has really really important in
making interdisciplinary research in the
sciences especially with connection to
biodiversity and environmental issues
happening here at Yale so super excited
to also have some of the board members
here and be able to meet some more of
them later this afternoon thanks to you
all for coming
we're in the midst of a new recently
introduced break a deal sort of fall
break number one so many of the students
and even faculty are out of town so it
won't be a huge crowd I think it will be
filling in a little bit in the afternoon
as some other events are finishing up
but in a way this is about communicating
our work and this theme to the to the yo
community better I'm also really excited
and that is a major objective of their
get together here to just talk to one
another the people in the room but also
symposium participants and we have some
discussion sessions tomorrow where we
hope to follow up and talk more about
working together realizing the synergies
in this broader area of biodiversity
science at a global scale now you can't
really think about biodiversity species
or even jeans individuals or biological
mechanisms without also at least a bit
thinking about the spatial context the
spatial dimension so the spatial context
is that the cynical unknown the absolute
necessity I'd say for truly and
competitively understanding many perhaps
all biodiversity mechanisms affecting
biodiversity and it's also absolutely
essential for doing successful
conservation now a broad scale is
important for obvious reasons less than
six or seven or so bird species
are actually out of 600-700 are actually
restricted to Europe only five or six
lesson of a third or so of the reptiles
of the United States are actually
restricted to the United States into
Mexico the national mistake in having
multiple on the barrel very relaxed so
quotes given every perspective it's
absolutely essential to send many
important affections in wireless designs
and certainly to to comprehensive
consolation prizes privatization
thinking about the
that's kind of what supposed to set the
scene in a way for for this symposium
Yale has had a of course in history of
thinkers in ecology and also a
conservation Aldo Leopold was part was
in this department the school of
Forestry environmental sciences it's the
founder of wildlife management science
if you will
Hutchinson will in Hutchinson was just
over there in that building and he's one
of the founders of ecology as we all
know I think they would approve of us
getting together today and and thinking
very much about space thinking about
geography about the geographic context
of biodiversity something that hasn't
been that strong at Yale we are lacking
at geography department here and we've
been lacking really a strong critical
mass of ecologists for the last 10 20
years but I hope or our hope here is and
I'm just speaking on behalf of the
steering committee of that new program
which includes Ron Smith there Michael
Donohue Dave Skelly and Eric's Argos and
as many other associated a faculty I
think I speak for all of them with and I
say that you're all hoping to grow this
area and put Yale back on the map again
in this interdisciplinary arena of
biodiversity science with spatial and
geographic component and with that I
would like to invite the first speaker